my name is Chan Chi Cheung and the
project that I've been working on it's
the learning of 3d shape priors that can
be helped used to help with other 3d
tasks so what is a shape prior basically
it's the sense of what a shape should
look like so for example if I take my
two random chairs of different styles
and then I put the back of one chair on
the seat of the other one then I'll end
up getting in shape that can be defined
as a chair but probably you'll say that
this chair looks weird it doesn't look
right so this is because we've built a
sense of what it should look like
over years of seeing like different
kinds of chairs so right now we try to
build a neural network that models this
kind of knowledge so for a model part we
train a generator over several networks
so this is so these are two networks one
of which we call a generator that tries
to generate a shape that looks like the
shape in a given dataset and then the
discriminator tries to distinguish
between the generator shape and the real
shape so these two compete against each
other and when the training converged
the generator will be able to sample new
shapes that looks like real shapes that
looks reasonable and the discriminator
will be able to tell if a shape looks
natural so then we can use this network
to have with our tasks like 3d shape
reconstruction so that we can make the
reconstructions also have more details
and looks more natural